and we have new information this morning
on how the covid-19 pandemic may have
started the department of energy says it
has data that supports the theory that
the covet outbreak began with a
laboratory leak in Wuhan China senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge has been covering this story
for us for years Catherine good morning
other parts of the Intel Community have
different conclusions what are your
sources telling you well good morning
Tony two sources familiar with the U.S
government's covid-19 Origins
investigation tell CBS News there is new
reporting from the Department of energy
that supports the lab League Theory as
plausible the sources confirm the
department of energy has low confidence
in the finding first reported by The
Wall Street Journal though it's not
clear whether that reflects weak data or
a limited amount of information well the
new reporting is classified the sources
say they believe it may be separate from
an earlier analysis by the department of
Energy's Lawrence Livermore Labs which
is home to some of the government's most
qualified biologists that assessment
also pointed to a potential access a
dental lab leak in Wuhan China well
there's no consensus among U.S
intelligence officials about how the
pandemic started the FBI and now the
energy Department have both found an
accidental lab leak increasingly
plausible the US government ultimately
wants to nail down answers to not only
how covid-19 killed over a million
Americans but also how to prevent it
from happening in the Future Tony
yeah and Catherine there are huge
political and diplomatic implications as
well which raises the question of why it
is just so hard to know exactly where
this pandemic started well that's right
the World Health Organization has met
several roadblocks because of the
Chinese government's persistent lack of
cooperation nearly two years ago a CBS
News investigation spoke with current
and former government officials who said
there was significant circumstantial
evidence that supported the lab leak
Theory there remains little evidence
they said that the virus infected humans
through animals Tony
so where does the investigation go from
here
Ohio Congressman Mike Turner told CBS
News in December that Republicans on the
house intelligence committee will issue
subpoenas to the intelligence Community
to gather information about the origins
of the covid-19 pandemic still three
years since the pandemic began critics
say no meaningful policy changes have
been made to address potential future
outbreaks Tony
all right got it for now Catherine thank
you very much you're welcome